hi there Steve coffin here and we are
now in week 9 of our 12 week or 90-day
language challenge in my case it's
Persian and Arabic and many of you are
doing other languages and we want to in
this sort of 12-week period we want to
achieve a breakthrough and one of the
subjects that always comes up is
pronunciation so obviously I believe
firmly that input is the key to language
acquisition and a lot of research
supports this and through input
activities like listening and reading we
improve our comprehension we acquire
words we acquire phrases our overall
skill in the language improves what
about the ability to pronounce I
wouldn't use the word correctly but to
get closer and closer to native
pronunciation because our goal is to get
as close as we can to the way the native
speaker and we can choose if we live in
Australia we want to sound like an
Australian if presumably if we're even
if we live in Quebec we want to sound
like a Quebec wash we live in Taiwan we
want to sound like a Taiwanese person or
we may not we may decide that we prefer
to speak with a you know Beijing accent
or whatever but the point is we choose
the form of the native speakers accent
that we want to try to imitate get as
close to as possible but we have to be
realistic we are unlikely to end up
sounding like a native speaker like
exactly like a native speaker and that's
okay
most people who speak a second language
fluently eloquently competently have an
accent and that is not a problem
and I think that's the first thing I
really want to stress the people that
impressed me the most when I hear them
in English are those people who use the
language well who have a lot of words
who use the language accurately the odd
mistake perhaps but a lot of words to
express their thoughts so that's got to
be the goal and usually people who use
the language well who have a large
vocabulary who understand well usually
they have an acceptable accent that
means to say we can understand them
because people who speak well usually
have done a lot of listening and have
done a lot of speaking because when we
engage with people in the language we
also pick up on their accent alright we
normally we're very easily influenced by
what we hear around us so if you do the
normal things in terms of listening and
reading and speaking your pronunciation
will improve however there are some
specific things I think that can be done
to improve one's pronunciation to get
closer to the desired accent which as I
say it could be French from France from
southern France
it could be German from Bavaria it could
be Japanese from the Osaka region
whatever it is that we want to imitate
we're gonna listen to it and over and
over again in order to get that
pronunciation in us so but some bits of
advice first of all we should not be too
influenced by our own writing system so
if we are used to reading in English we
mustn't assume that Spanish
pronunciation gives the same value to
the writing to the letters as we do in
English I can remember being in Japan
and I introduced Canadian English
speaker to a mr. Kotter
and they said mr. Kittel I mean I just
finished saying cut oh and they say
caked-on ignore the value of the letters
in your own language the reverse is also
true Japanese people who learn English
and who use katakana use their own or
hiragana their own
usually katakana their own writing
system as a guide to the pronunciation
in English they will be in trouble you
have to rely on what you hear you have
to see the relationship between the
language as written in the target
language and the way it's pronounced you
have to focus on them and hear it and if
you do that enough the brain will get
used to it so you can't pronounce
correctly what you don't hear so you
first of all you have to get used to
allowing yourself to hear how the
language is pronounced without any
preconceived ideas coming from your own
language okay second of all so to review
here you have to do a lot of reading and
a lot of listening let the sounds bounce
on your brain you have to be open to the
way the language is pronounced not have
preconceived ideas about how you think
it should be pronounced based on your
own writing system and third of all you
have to want to there has to be an
emotional attachment to that
pronunciation otherwise there's a
tendency to hang back in what's familiar
what's comfortable but you have to be
willing to say okay I am Chinese
I am Russia I am French and you pretend
to be that nationality you pretend to be
a native speaker of that language even
though you don't achieve it you pretend
to be it there has to be that commitment
to pronouncing okay
all the while accepting the fact that
you needn't be perfect you needn't be
accent free you want to speak well in
the language you want to pretend you are
one of them but you won't you'll fall
short okay you'll parcel so that has to
be a part of the equation you can like
through a lot of listing you will notice
how the language is pronounced you'll
notice most things but there are some
things you won't notice so there I think
it's a good idea to read sort of a
description of pronunciation in this
language you can read it when you start
out it won't make much of an impression
because you don't yet have a sense of
the language it might help a bit I
wouldn't try to nail anything down and
then at various times you can re-read
sort of an explanation of the
pronunciation and you may pick up a few
things that will be helpful as you try
to sort of notice and imitate the
language to me that's the main thing be
relaxed about it
don't be hung up about it the more
relaxed you are the better the more you
engage with the language the better the
better you use the language the better
your pronunciation will be and the more
you speak the better you'll get and you
have to be open you have to be open one
thing I should point out that's probably
beyond the reach of many people but it's
something that I'm convinced of and that
is that when we only have one language
say English or Japanese or French then
we are very much influenced by that
language if we learn a second language
we are now exposed to more sounds and so
therefore when we go to Laura learn a
third or fourth language we are more
open more flexible when it comes to
sounds so obviously if you're learning
your first second language then you are
dealing with that problem so you have to
be as open as possible to the new sounds
if you choose to learn a third language
you'll probably find that pronunciation
in that third language will be easier so
those are my bits of advice on
pronunciation keep an open mind
continue your main input activities
speak as much as you can don't worry
about it but allow yourself
pretend like imitate be the person of
that language that you are learning and
good luck to you in your translation bye
for now